draw two points on a circle and connect
them obviously this divides the circle
into two different regions if you put a
third point on the circle and then draw
lines connecting it to the previous
points now the circle's been divided
into four separate regions at a fourth
Point add lines connecting it to all the
previous ones and again count up how
many regions the circle's been divided
into this time we get eight if you start
to see the pattern let's do one more at
a fifth Point connect it to all the
previous ones count up the regions and
this time we get 16 again maybe you can
guess what's coming next but would You
Bet Your Life on it well let's try I'll
add a sixth Point connect it to all of
the previous ones and this time if I go
through and meticulously count all the
regions you can pause and do it yourself
I'm not pulling any trickery here you
actually get 31 be careful of
extrapolating patterns without proof in
this case there's a very good reason why
it looks like powers of two until
suddenly breaking at the sixth iteration
it's a little too long for a short form
explanation but before watching the full
video on YouTube I highly encourage you
to try thinking it through yourself